people now come here to get rich 20
years ago theoretically this was a city
built on public service hi I'm Nicolas
be with reason TV and today we are
talking with mark leibovich he is the
author of the controversial and highly
publicized book this town two parties in
a funeral plus plenty of valet parking
in America's Gilded capital mark thanks
for talkin it good to be here okay you
are at the new york times magazine
you've been Washington Post reporter San
Jose Mercury News you you have covered
this town for a long time this town and
there's certainly a lot in this book for
a Washington hitter to grab on to I mean
you thought you know Tim Russert funeral
is like a scene from Fellini but you it
is easy to come away thinking that you
love this town I don't love this town
I've been looking for an excuse to live
elsewhere for many years the fact is I
mean my job is here and my wife's job is
here our kids are here our life is here
our schools are you i'm pretty sure if
you move the kids will follow a wife
with no and that could be infant no i
mean look it's it's a nice place to
raise a family very pleasant and we're
all very lucky in our employment stone
who are the who are the status brokers
in DC currently who are the people
because in a lot of ways this book it's
it's about cocktail parties it's about
who gets the valet the best valet
parking slot who shows up at tim russert
funeral who are the big status players
right now i mean first of all I mean I
think the major point of the book is if
government and Washington and the whole
entourage of Washington has gotten so
big that really their barriers to entry
in the status game have sort of fallen
through the floor and anyone you know
without facial warts can go on cable and
be called the strategists and all of a
sudden you're doing paid speeches and so
forth so I mean I guess one person I
focus on is Bob Barnett who's a lawyer
in town represents Democrats Republicans
broadcast journalists I mean he's he
calls himself a doorman of the revolving
door which is pretty interesting he
doesn't say give us names of some of his
clients Barack Obama Michelle Obama
George W Bush Laura Bush Dick Cheney
Sarah Palin room
get out the debate the clintons goes and
he represents everyone we talked about
what is the connection between status
and power because and our people in DC
are they after status or are they after
power I don't know some combination of
both I mean I certainly increasingly
thereafter money i mean washington is
the wealthiest community in the united
states right now it's home to seven of
the wealthiest ten counties or the
united states and the reason we chart
that with with alarm as I imagine you
should I think most people should and I
think I mean it parted obviously a big
part of this is the growth of government
but but a lot of is the derivative
seconders around the growth of
government whether it's lobbying any
number of consulting things and and look
I mean I think one of the biggest
changes here over the last couple of
decades is that people now come here to
get rich 20 years ago theoretically this
was a city built on public service I
think it's been given over to
self-service instead of feeding it a
much broader trough our people in
Washington the people who actually make
the big differences in everyday life and
are the people who are seeking status
here are they the ones who are creating
the the context for the invasion of
Syria are they the ones who are telling
the NSA you know start looking at
everything we're doing or you know is
this where it all happens and then how
does that feedback into the kind of
spectacular carnival right I mean that's
a great point I mean I think first of
all I mean I've tried not to focus too
much on the trivial players I mean some
might say that okay I focus on a party
host here and an agent here and everyone
sort of operating and that's you know
they're really not known to people but I
think ultimately it begins with the
government I mean when you have someone
like Tom Daschle who's one of the most
powerful Democrats in Washington you
know leaves the senate voted out of the
Senate is now one of the most powerful
corporate consultants he would never
call himself a lobbyist or strategic
consultant whatever he calls himself
still obviously talks to his former
Senate colleagues every day and now he
could not become the secretary of health
and human services so write me right he
have tax problems so what yeah and he
obviously he realized that his
compensation actually included what he
was being paid not just what he decided
to declare there was a limo but you know
so is he Pat is I mean is that a sign
that he's very powerful or is it a sign
that actually these people
want to believe that they're powerful
but they're being dictated to great
distinction I mean first of all these
people want to believe they're powerful
but more importantly people want to
believe that they're powerful and they
hire them and we are talking about
billions in corporate and trade and
government money that is going to
ultimately support a sector I mean I
guess the term I would use I mean Tom
Coburn who's one of the characters in
this book one of the heroes I like to
think I look I I mean I love talking to
Tom Coburn I think Tom Coburn has a
great view of what the big picture here
is and his word for is the permanent
feudal class of Washington DC and I
think it's a great way of putting it's
just this sprawling I mean he says he
talked about parasitism Zand it compares
it to the intestines and he's a doctor
so he gets all I'll colorful and he's
famous for giving a slideshow a
PowerPoint presentation of STDs to DC in
turn so yeah he can really go with
heated yes he subtlety has never been
one of his things but no but but dr.
Coburn or senator Coburn is someone who
I think has really named this in a way
that that I was very very taken by do
you think Coburn is he exemplary in the
sense that he I mean he's somebody who
has definite principles he's willing to
negotiate on things that aren't central
or even you know that he you know where
he can get more good than bad is he
typical of politicians in that he has
principles so he can negotiate or do
most of the people in Congress and most
of the people around them is it that
they don't have core principles and as a
result they really can't negotiate or
they will they will always cut a deal or
they will never cut a deal it's
obviously case by case but I do think
that I mean in senator Coburn's case he
began and he's I think he will always be
known as a very principled guy a lot of
people credit him as being the father of
the Tea Party openly but but look he he
is he's actually quite independent I
mean he has a friendship of Barack Obama
that seems pretty genuine and also he
has a level of credibility now just
probably by a seniority but also the
fact that he gets a lot of attention is
his own ecosystem that allows him to be
pragmatic and maybe deal more than he
would he also has term-limited himself
in a way that most people sometimes will
don't meet I mean
yeah it will not run beyond he's
determined well in he had of course term
loaded himself as a congress and he said
when he was leaving that you know only
psychotics want to be here and then came
back a few years later I don't put in
the cs true yeah that does tend to mom
well you know I guess to continue on
this train of thought you you know at
one point you call DC the country's most
powerful prosperous and disappointing
city explain that I think it's well
certainly powerful and it's a seat of
the federal government is prosperous for
their all the reasons I just mentioned I
mean it's doing exceedingly well it's
disappointing I mean just if you talk to
most Americans or look at polls and they
talk about I mean if they were you were
to ask them to talk about the
performance of their government
Democrats Republicans the media I mean
just the whole DC establishment do you
have a sense among the media are among
DC people or the great American masses
are people disappointed that government
is not doing things or that they're not
doing the right things probably
combination of both I think though one
thing I came away with is the system
here the machinery here has gotten so
big and the lie has gotten so baked into
the day-to-day conversation whether it's
the I didn't mean that term limits thing
or I didn't mean that corporate
donations thing or I didn't mean that no
lobbying in the White House thing
because here's an exception here there's
a level that Oh predominate look
everyone can make a living everyone can
do what they want everyone can lie there
is a level that I think just the size
and the cynicism and and just that the
inhumanity that has grown up can we talk
a little bit about because Obama
President Obama is obviously a character
in the book and you mentioned at one
point Obama whose favorite movie is the
godfather and who has something of a mob
fetish how does that play into what you
were just talking about either the lie
or the wheel and wheeler and dealer the
you know the multiple faces Obama
arguably in a reason and I think
everywhere certainly at the New York
Times The Washington Post everywhere the
Bush presidency was a disaster on every
level from the bushes perspective as
well as everybody else Obama was going
to change all that he was mr.
transparent he was shining
any prints on a horse coming into town
terrible on transparency terrible on
lobbyists you know the revolving door
etc how is he upping the game in terms
of the level of cynicism and in
incapacity for taking the government
seriously I think it's very possible i
mean i think look he was supposed to be
different and everyone claims are going
to be different never i claim they're
gonna be a change is and everyone claims
are going to drain the swamp and then
you know if you settle into it like a
warm bath great i mean presidents are
always on a different plane because one
they don't tend to stay they can they're
in their own ecosystem they can leave
they can you know make zillions of
dollars doing whatever they want to do
but no i mean i think barack obama is a
incredibly pragmatic politician he's an
incredibly astute politician I mean I
think the Godfather analogy which he's
used himself is is right which is that
he he sees this maybe as a Machiavellian
game and I think he has ideals I think
he believes a lot of what he says but I
think ultimately he is a player of the
game and he's been very effective what
is the way and not to drain the swamp
but maybe to ratchet down the level of
cynicism and disbelief in government
both you know both among the voters but
then especially among people in the
system right because if they're if
they're believing everybody's full of
[ __ ] everybody's lying words don't mean
anything right then nothing can change
how do you make how do you affect a
change yeah I mean look I mean at first
of all time I'm not a solutions and
change guy i mean i don't know but i
think that look at my journalistic
formula and a lot of people have said
where's your conclusion what are your 10
right pacific my journalistic formula is
shining a light on maybe the culture and
maybe shame ultimately i mean i think
look I mean aight what i try to do is
give voice to the entire carnival here
and sort of to try to give readers
outside of Washington who might have a
intuitive sense that Washington is not a
great place these days a fuller sense of
what the full movie looks like if it is
I mean this is kind of a systems
approach it doesn't matter what widget
shows up here it's going to come out
looking the same after a couple years
yeah so then how do you I mean that
really does beg before what's wrong with
the system and then
who you know are we looking if we're
looking in DC for the architect of the
system and how to control or how to
change it maybe that's the wrong place
maybe well I think what that's an
interesting point because I think if you
do I mean one of the sources of optimism
that I feel in the course of my job and
and people say I'm a cynic people say I
tear down the city and whatever I mean I
my wife at least things I'm an optimist
one source of optimism is I get to leave
Washington periodically my job allows me
to leave Washington and and let populist
movements are easily dismissed here but
they can be very very powerful I mean I
guess the reason example is I mean gay
marriage immigration we wouldn't be
having these conversations here if it
weren't for the where the numbers are
out in the drug legalization as well as
another case where these these are
things that are happening at well
outside of this address right amateur
and that eventually whether it's shame
or just pragmatism will drive Washington
you know to to some kind of movement I
think though what I'm focusing on here
is again to shine a light on that
permanent feudal class to give people a
fuller sense I guess you would say of
the horror what we will leave it there
we've been talking with mark leibovich
is the author of the I'm trying to give
it the do credit it deserves
entertaining irresistible heartbreaking
stomach-churning it's called mark
leibovich the the author of this town
two parties in a funeral plus plenty of
valet parking in America's Gilded
capital thanks so much for talking to
reason TV Thank You ppreciate
you